nous sommes avec fabrice epelboin
enseignant à sciences po spécialiste du
numérique bonjour monsieur epelboin
merci d'être en direct avec nous alors
tout d'abord partagez-vous les mêmes
craintes que ce collectif qui dénoncent
la légalité des transferts vers les
états unis
les partages mais c'est pas la
principale crainte qu'ont à avoir face à
ce projet effectivement la fin du prabé
si j'ai vu d'un pose un problème
juridique gigantesque du fait même que
ces données vont être opposés aux états
unis est traitée aux états unis et au
passage elles devront être visibles et
c'est à dire non chiffrée par les
ingénieurs de microsoft aux états unis
parce que certains traitements
d'intelligence artificielle ne peuvent
se faire que là bas et donc ça roule
ensemble complètement caduque d'un point
de vue juridique
mais le plus gros problème n'est pas là
le plus gros problème est que nous
confions ce qui va permettre de
construire le système de santé demain de
la france à un acteur américain qui va
le traiter sur le territoire américain
et on a un autre acteur du même ordre
qui est google qui est déjà en train de
nous apporter des assurances santé
personnalisé qui vont se baser sur tout
ce que google sait d'où ce qui veut dire
que demain
très concrètement on pourra vous donner
à vous une mutuelle à un prix compétitif
incroyable mais par contre à votre mari
à qui on aura détecté une probabilité de
cancer dans les dix ans lionla sur
appart et donc on va aller vers une
société ultra inégalitaire du fait de ce
capitalisme de surveillance qui sait
tout absolument tout sur nous y compris
des données médicales qu'on ignore nous
mêmes parce qu'il a ses outils
d'intelligence artificielle qu'on a
aussi par ailleurs qui permettent
d'extrapoler un futur par rapport à
l'observation d'une masse de présents
pourquoi jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'ya pas
d'hébergement en france pourquoi vers
les états unis on n'a pas encore mise au
point justement un système comme celui
là on a des systèmes régalien français
et européens on a un acteur extrêmement
connue en france de l'hébergement qui
s'appelle ovh qui vient de signer un
partenariat et c'est la lyre audi avec t
mobile c'est-à-dire avec le premier
opérateur allemand et donc
nécessairement le gouvernement allemand
qui est derrière qu'il opérait qui sera
son conseil d'administration et pendant
que ces projets européens se
construisent
le gouvernement français confie l'avenir
de cheetah naissance et français à des
âmes et les cas quand on regarde le
système de santé américain
on est quand même en droit de se poser
des questions là on part donc à dire à
la décision de la cour européenne de
justice a invalidé justement le bouclier
de protection des données entre l'europe
et les états unis ce que cela peut
changer la donne et faire infléchir la
position du conseil d'état selon vous
c'est clair que si cette invalidation
persiste si on n'a pas comme la dernière
fois
un nouveau petit fils de bricoler à
larache ne pas seulement à pouvoir
colmater les brèches
ça rend le projet totalement caduque on
n'aura plus droit de faire ce genre de
choses ça rend également la position de
facebook extrêmement délicat que ça rend
la position d'une quantité faramineuse
de sociétés technologiques très complexe
parce que jusqu'ici il faut bien le dire
on y vivait dans un monde sont une
hypocrisie qui consiste tout simplement
à faire croire à au législateur parce
que le groupe béké pas dupe que les
données d'aidé européen a envoyé aux
états unis n'étaient pas à risque
or depuis la sphère soden on sait
pertinemment que les données sur le
territoire américain et bien au delà son
service par la nasa
donc on vit dans cette hypocrisie
juridique qui vient de tomber reste à
voir si l'europe va remettre à nouveau
une petite couche d'hypocrisie comme
elle l'avait fait précédemment ou si là
on va vraiment regarder les choses en
face est vraiment décidé d'avoir une
souveraineté au niveau 6 les français du
moins européen dernière question se
souvient que l'ancien ministre de la
santé
alliès busin avait affirmé que les
données seraient anonymes quelles sont
les chances justement que ces données
et déjà été récupérés par des états ou
en vous comme l'essentiel de ce 4 mai à
radès busin ces derniers temps c'est
totalement faux non seulement ces
données ne peuvent pas être anonyme
parce que quand vous avez une telle
cohorte de données il y a toujours pas
son nom de reconstituer l'identité des
possesseurs de la donne et ça a été
démontré par la plupart des grandes
universités de la planète ont fait leur
démonstration parce que ça fait partie
des choses il faut montrer d'un point de
vue cryptographique pour faire état de
son savoir mais on ne peut pas
anonymisées ce genre de données par
ailleurs le chiffrement qui permettrait
éventuellement de les rendre totalement
lisible à quelqu'un qui pourrait accéder
au réseau n'est pas possible dans ce cas
de figure parce que le traitement
particulier des données sur cette base
d'intelligence artificielle nécessite de
donner les clés de déchiffrement à
microsoft
ça a été confirmé par le rapport de la
cnil merci beaucoup
fabrice epelboin de nous avoir éclairé
sur ce sujet je rappelle que vous êtes
enseignant à sciences po et spécialiste
du numérique